je vous présente les résidents
d'éléments City
les aériens ont souvent la tête dans les
nuages oh non ma nouvelle veste les
terriens sont un peu fleur bleue
circulez il y a rien à voir juste un peu
des
aquatiques n'hésite jamais à se mouiller
[Musique]
et vous les flamboyants votre commande
on est tout fait tout flamme
[Musique]
cette boutique est le rêve de notre
famille et un jour elle sera toi mais
nous cohabitons grâce à une règle d'or
le feu et l'eau ne peuvent pas être en
couple
mon père te ferait bouillir à feu vif
mais de quel droit les gens peuvent te
dire ce que tes censé faire ou pas
on se demande à quoi servent ces
grillages
j'ai l'impression que tu as changé
[Musique]
un aquatique c'est ici que tu habites
c'est l'appartement de ma mère et on
a Marco Polo
j'ai essayé d'être à la hauteur de mon
père mais je ne me suis jamais demandé
ce que je rêvais de faire
tout est dans cela arrête ils sont trop
chauds ceux-là
[Musique]
tu vois il adore ça